[Music]
kevin great to have you with us
thank you great to be here all right
kevin as wonderful as it is to have mr
wonderful we also have quant maestro and
bitcoin og roy niederhoffer roy has been
a bitcoin bull since 2011. he's the
president and founder of rg nederhoffer
capital management a diversified hedge
fund with nearly a billion dollars of
assets under management roy good to have
you with us
thanks michelle great to see you again
all right kevin let's start with you and
let's start with a macro picture because
it's now exactly one month since putin
invaded ukraine and the conflict is not
going as he expected we've got these
rising geopolitical tensions sanctions
on russia seeing a surge in commodity
prices the imf is now projecting global
growth to slow down by at least one and
a half percent in 2022
we have inflation at 40-year highs here
in the u.s the fed hiking rates for the
first time since 2018.
powell says he still thinks he's going
to be able to like to rate to her hike
rates at least six times this year and
we've got recession projections
increasing goldman saying there's a 35
percent chance of recession over the
next year so let's start with your big
macro economic read on the environment
kevin
yeah for as tragic as the russia ukraine
situation is as far as markets and
investing go i don't put much weight on
it i'll explain why that represents less
than one percent of the s p earnings no
matter how you triangulate it um
obviously these sanctions are
unprecedented in economic pressure
and the fact that the swiss actually
shut down russian accounts is also
unprecedented now as far as crypto goes
and you know roy and i are obviously
focused on that
i don't think that matters as much as
this what i call
four vectors of policy coming at crypto
right now let me walk just through the
shopping list this is also unprecedented
number one you got the loomis spill and
it's mostly positive i've read it a lot
of positive policy in that number two
you've got the executive order from
biden that says we must embrace this and
regulate it also good news it could have
gone the other way he could have said we
want to make this illegal number three
you've got the sec
talking about carpet audits and i'll get
to that in a moment that just happened
last week
and number four you've got this
remarkable situation coming out of
blackrock the world's largest money
manager uh decrying and
talking about bitcoin mining and carbon
credits not aligning and and i think
there's a lot of of of
policy in all of that but the fact that
that's all happening shows you that
crypto is never going away and i think
the more it gets regulated the more
institutional assets flow into this
asset class
and i want to initially separate the
concept of bitcoin and cryptos for this
question because i'd like for you to
make your case for bitcoin in this
current environment
my view right now is that
the russian conflict has
made the case for
one of the best features of bitcoin
which it's which is of course that it's
always there wherever you are
so the initial attraction i had for the
asset back in 2011 was it seemed to
solve a historical problem which is how
to take your things from place to place
if they're too big to carry and of
course bitcoin is always there on the
blockchain wherever you are so in terms
of asset transport
it's pretty clear that there's a great
use case for it but we have a much
bigger situation happening and it has
really very little to do with russia and
ukraine
for me the big reason to be interested
in bitcoin and the space in general but
in particular the largest assets in the
space bitcoin and ether
is that the balance sheet expansion of
the federal reserve has gotten so far
out of control that there is no heading
off inflation caused by the printing of
dollars
now a lot of people blame things like
gas prices at 430 a gallon which is
where they are right now
on the russia conflict but that's not
what caused it in my view maybe the last
few tens of cents but in reality we
already had gas at three dollars and 40
cents a gallon up almost 50 percent in
the last 12 months before the ukraine
conflict even began
and that's caused by too many dollars
chasing too few goods so what i'm going
to do right now is make a case
that i think is going to make a very
reasonable
sensible
uh prediction
that we get bitcoin prices
10
1000 and even 10 000 times what the
price is right now now that sounds
probably a little crazy but let me take
you through it
right now the inflation rate is about 10
percent
i think most people would make a say
it's fairly reasonable to think that we
could have 10
inflation for another 20 or 30 years
that doesn't sound so out of control
um
[Music]
it's also reasonable to think that
bitcoin itself grows from where it is
right now it's about the size of the
thai bot
and if bitcoin happens to get a little
more acceptance and grows to the market
cap of the british pound that's about
five times what it is right now you put
those together in 20 years you have a
bitcoin price 30 times what it is now
in 30
uh 85 times what it is right now so
we're talking about a bitcoin price of
3.8 million
even if a very reasonable current
assumption holds true
and we can go beyond that let's say
there's 15
inflation for 30 years
and the bitcoin market cap rivals that
of the euro we're talking about a
bitcoin price of 56 million and if
bitcoin becomes the world reserve
currency
and we have 20 inflation the bitcoin
price is going to be almost 500 million
and remember it's trading at 45 000
approximately right now
so these are edge cases i admit you'll
probably look at this in 20 years and
say wow what a what a silly idea that
was to predict that but i think they are
non-zero cases there are reasonable
assumptions to make and for many other
reasons i think it's a very interesting
investment right now
all right roy so you're saying that
there is
an edge case of bitcoin at 500 million
in the next 30 years
yes and that is not even a
hyperinflationary case
hyperinflation we we'd be talking about
billions or trillions of course the
dollar would be essentially worthless at
that point
kevin what are your thoughts do you
think that roy could be on to something
here with this hypothesis
i think
it's impossible to predict price or
volatility
and obviously
the trend is your friend and as far as
bitcoin is concerned we have i think
what affects price near term and midterm
more than anything else is to get policy
out of the u.s regulator on bitcoin
and stable coins the two that if you
read the loomis bill are really focus on
ethereum bitcoin and stable coins and so
that's that's interesting because the
fact is
today and i work in the indexing market
where we try and index for institutions
i'll give you an example if you're a
sovereign wealth fund in the middle east
and you want exposure some of these
countries generate 250 million dollars
of cash a day and they want obviously to
get diversification they already have
oil so they want the s p 500 x energy
and two years ago they started saying
well we're not allowed to own bitcoin
but how do we get exposure to
bitcoin volatility and at that time the
way that was really working was many
companies had raised capital uh in the
us markets that were bitcoin miners pure
miners
they just
they were awarded coins they kept them
on their balance sheet and the theory
was that if you owned the equities you
could get exposure in a legitimate way
to the volatility and indeed if you look
at the price of bitcoin vis-a-vis
let's call an index of some of the
popular ones that would be hud-8
marathon riot and hive
which were very popular to be indexed
they really traded in tandem with
bitcoin so it worked for a while but
that's why i talked about the four
vectors that correlation is going to
fall off pretty quickly now that um we
have for the first time calls for carbon
audits because most of the public
companies in the u.s that have been used
for proxies
have been saying okay
we'll just buy some carbon offsets and
that worked fine but
now that the sec wants to audit this you
can't find an auditor that's willing to
sign off on that ledger because you
can't say i'm using you know dirty
energy to mine coin and i bought you
know an acre of the amazon forest and
try and
and pass them off it doesn't work
there's no way to audit carbon credits
so we are in a bit of a uh
let's call it a bit of a pickle right
now um
and i'll i'll be frank and transparent
on this i have dumped all those stocks
uh as soon as i read the executive order
out of biden i sold it which stocks are
those the the money specifically yeah
specifically we owned uh hud we were
indexing
some of our man
my mandate i can't own bitcoin i mean i
can own it personally but if it's an
operating company i can't do it because
we don't have a regulation a rule on
that yet and that's why most of it is
actually held by high net worth and
hedge funds like roy's where they don't
have that compliance issue i do have a
compliance issue so we indexed and it
was working just great uh marathon
fantastic trading vehicle against the
price of bitcoin riot
hot 8
um
and hive and so
they're good liquid stocks they're easy
to get in and out of but i don't own a
single share dump them all i mean they
are they're going to be forced they're
going to be they're going to run into
carbon audits and their expenses are
going to go up
and we can talk about where capital is
flowing but it certainly isn't that
model anymore
okay but before we get into that and
touch on the esg topic which you were
well ahead of the curve on uh kevin i
just want you to go back to roy's macro
hypothesis here and all the elements
that he's brought into it including this
hyperinflation
does it fit within your realms of
possibility that we do hit that kind of
high for bitcoin in 30 years or
is that not even something that you
think is feasible
you can't say that it's a zero
as roy pointed out his scenario when he
talks about these extreme prices is
hyperinflation 15 20 25 percent i don't
know if that's going to happen but i am
on board with him on the train as your
friend on pricing i think the reason we
own so much bitcoin and ethereum right
now and 32 other positions is i believe
this sector will be the 12th sector of
the s p as you pointed out earlier and i
believe that you want diversification
when i own the sector like energy in the
s p i i have no position more than five
percent well i have 32 positions on and
my view is simply that bitcoin is not a
coin it's software ethereum's software
polygon software it's alone and software
all of this stuff is software so i'm
just investing in software development
that has the potential to provide
productivity and the market will value
it based on its scarcity in the case of
bitcoin or the proposal of economic uh
in
increase like a polygon reducing fees
and friction and you know hbar being
used by boeing for supply chain
management all of these different
scenarios i don't know which one's going
to work but i don't need them all to
work i just need a few to work and i'm
going to make a ton of money that's the
way i look at it
all right uh roy how are you allocating
your crypto portfolio at the moment and
i'd like to point out that you bought
bitcoin in 2011 i believe it was ten
dollars at the time and you also bought
ethereum uh in the double digits so when
we know ethereum's at 3100 so you've
obviously called these uh protocols
coins correctly
give us your portfolio breakdown right
now
well i i'm
a big believer in having the blue chip
names in any index and concentrating on
those so
i think right now it's a very tough call
to pick us a
altcoin let's call them let's call them
the uh number six to 20 coins things
like terra solana polka dot avalanche
these are coins that have about
20 to 30 billion dollars in market cap
when we talk about bitcoin we're at 841
eth is at 375.
so what that means is you're looking at
for an institutional investor
something that has 20 30 40 times the
liquidity
and what this means is that if
my scenario becomes
a possibility let's say and institutions
go into the space
they're going to go for the largest
coins
because that's where the liquidity is no
one ever got fired for investing in
cryptocurrency in bitcoin well maybe
they did but if you have to explain why
you picked polka dot and not avalanche
when avalanche was the one that went up
and polka dot went down that's a much
tougher call but buying the big market
capital and i think is the first
step for most people it's the the
entry-level uh
trade but i think also because of the
liquidity in this trade that's where the
money is going to go
and to me
the largest prize here
and the offset idea the the
moral good
comparing compared to the
carbon emissions and all the other
things that might be bad about bitcoin
the holy grail of this space is to give
billions of people the access to lending
to investments to savings and to money
transfer in a form
that is supply constrained
and ubiquitous
all over the world that's never happened
before
all of those things either were
impossible from
a good chunk of the world's population
to access or they had to access it in
the form of their local currency which
has enormous risk and can be devalued
and in fact if you look historically
almost or near or even exactly a hundred
percent of all fiat currencies have been
devalued by 99 plus percent
over say a 200 year period there are
maybe only a couple of exceptions for
that and i think that's where we're
headed in the united states the value of
the us dollar is down about 99 over the
last 120 years in real terms and i think
that's a risk that everyone faces to
offer
the world billions of people
decentralized finance
in a stable currency aka bitcoin is the
big prize and i think it's going to be
bitcoin that does it and it's been
demonstrated already technologically i
think that's what el salvador is seeing
already
kevin do you agree do you see bitcoin as
the ultimate prize the ultimate savior
in this uh economy and in this
environment
i see it as the number one destination
for institutions that are allowed to
index it when they can
index it they would be picking up one to
three percent waiting if they could they
tried to do it as i mentioned earlier
using equities that mine bitcoin
and that's in a bit of turmoil because
of esg mandates but bitcoin itself um
will provide enough liquidity for an
institution and i would add this
regardless of what you think your target
price is if it does become an indexed
asset and it and i think once the sec
mandates it it will the volatility will
decline dramatically because what
happens in an indexing model is when
prices decline and your weighting is one
and a half basis points or 150 bips you
simply buy up to 150 bip
maximum and when prices exceed that then
you trim back but that provides
tremendous stability for any asset so
you find that stocks that in that get
indexed or assets that could index all
of a sudden prices go up and stability
becomes part of what their story is for
a very long period of time now i'll add
that the canadian
regulator specifically the osc
in the last two years has been extremely
enlightened and they're not what i
believe this is a personal opinion and
i've said this before but i believe that
all the regulators talk to each other
practically every day but there's a
special relationship between the osc
and the sec because they they regulate
markets that are so similar in nature
and so i believe that whatever is going
on in ontario has already been quasi
approved by the brethren at the sec and
they're using ontario and the canadian
provinces as guinea pig states to try
these ideas out and what ideas are those
the first etf with the underlying asset
real bitcoin the first etf with the
underlying asset ethereum the very first
global
crypto exchange attached to a dealer
broker license both sides regulated that
was extraordinary that was called bit
buy i know that one because just a few
hours ago wonder if i acquired 100
percent of it so now wonderful which has
decentralized finance has combined with
centralized wallets that's never been
done before in addition to that the osc
has made the order by which that was
licensed public
many other jurisdictions are reading the
300 plus page document and using it as a
blueprint for other jurisdictions like
the united arab emirates in brazil and
switzerland and england so those
regulators are marching ahead making the
assumption that there will be sec
policies so if you're an investor now
like i am and clearly roy is
we take our positions pre the
stabilization of indexing by
institutions why we'll be rewarded for
taking that position now and when it
happens i don't know could be six months
12 months 18 months 24 months who knows
but when it happens prices are going
nowhere but up
kevin i completely agree with you i
think the uh
you're you're
you're making a really important point
about what speculators do
we recognize right now that the reason
that prices for these cryptocurrencies
are as low as they are
are all the fear uncertainty and doubt
that there is around them
and were those not to be the case you
suddenly have an asset that's worth 10
and 50x what it is right now
so i think that's really the a good
demonstration of the role of what uh
what people who invest the way we do are
are for i think you make another really
good point about the uh canadian
regulators making the case for uh for
cryptocurrencies
uh they also did something that i think
we have to mention
which was they took the bank accounts of
people whose behavior they didn't like
and that if there were ever a use case
for cryptocurrencies that is a very very
dangerous place for anyone with assets
to think that your behavior on the
ground could cause you to lose all of
your assets obviously russian oligarchs
are feeling the same way
and so i think when a government can
come and take your money be it reserve
assets or your bank account as a trucker
that's a time when you want to have your
assets everywhere in a highly protected
place
another reason i want to augment your
point about reducing volatility why
these things will be less
crazy to own they're not going to go up
five and ten percent and down five or
ten percent in a day anymore when things
stabilize
the reason for that will also be the
development of a robust derivatives
market we saw this happen with the s p
as the options market developed any
market that has a robust derivatives
market
will decline in volatility and if anyone
talked to me three years ago you know
how much i was complaining about no
volatility in the stock market there
will be a time when people complain
about the lack of volatility in bitcoin
rory and kevin price will be a lot
higher does the slack and we'll throw to
you first roy does this lack of
volatility mean that you're both are
anticipating mean that uh the potential
for dramatic price appreciations are
also going to be gone
absolutely one of the risks right now
when you buy bitcoin is it's going to go
down 50 90 we just had a what 70 or 80
percent decline through two years ago
right around this time two years ago
bitcoin was trading in the three
thousands even slightly below
so one one interesting piece of it is
that
ninety percent of the wealth in
cryptocurrencies has been created in the
last 24 months it's that new and a
reason why we're also today going to be
talking about decentralized finance and
all the opportunities is that
approximately two trillion in wealth
that's been created mostly over the last
two years okay
uh roy you've touched on two big themes
here regulation uh rather kevin you've
touched on two big themes regulation and
esg
and we know ethereum the second biggest
crypto by market cap very significant
development expected in june for
ethereum eth 2.0
that's expected to launch and that's
expected to be the merge of the
blockchain's proof of work and proof of
stake chains which reduces its energy
consumption dramatically now kevin you
again have long stated that institutions
focused on esg compliance and regulation
have been holding back because of this
esg concern and the rise of esg has put
the inefficiency of bitcoin's proof of
work model on investors radars just
recently the european union considered
banning bitcoin because of its
environmental impact so now we have eth
2.0 merging proof of work and proof of
stake and that is expected to reduce
energy consumption by about 99
so kevin do you think that esg concerns
will then take institutional money out
of bitcoin and into ethereum
so
let's just dissect that um and because
you've made you've made a few statements
there that are very important let's just
talk about ethereum 2.0 that has been on
the calendar for over two years
and um it's always just coming to a
theater near you
and the reason it doesn't happen that
quickly and probably won't happen on
schedule here is not everybody within
the east community agrees with this move
and there's a bunch of stakeholders that
don't benefit from a move like this
removing you know proof of work to prove
stake is not going to be to everybody's
benefit and so that fork in the road
could be a bump not not just an upside
and so i don't know the answer to that
um eath remains the platform of uh you
know
the standard if you wish but at this at
the end of the at the end of the day
it doesn't mean it'll be successful
let's go back to the comment regarding
um
you know all of this policy around esg
it is remarkable that you have both
government policy and private policy
dictated by the black rocks of the world
and corporations making claims of carbon
neutrality that all of this would be
happening at the same time that it takes
a lot of energy to actually be awarded a
coin and here's why i argue to investors
and institutional investors why it's a
good thing that there is proof of work
i'll walk you through it all right
in
america 85 of the dams that were created
in the last 150 years
contemplated turbine power however 85 of
them the turbines were never installed
now whose economic interest would it be
to go back
and install those turbines to get access
to 100 percent carbon neutral power i'd
argue that is going to be capital that
would set up data centers and mine
bitcoin
with 100 percent
hydroelectricity
in fact that has actually happened
already the capital that actually did
that was sovereign wealth out of the
middle east in norway
they've built out a facility on its way
to 300 megawatts
and we'll see that i think they're up at
40 already they have been hashing coins
since december it's the new model they
call it the norway model
100
compliant
and the actual institutions are not
allowed to own bitcoin that actually
funded that thing
but they're keeping every coin they're
awarded on the balance sheet and they've
done one thing else which i think will
become part of the new model and i'm
arguing now for why capital will pursue
this
they've been able to figure out a way to
take the network awards that you can
never allocate to where they came from
they could come from china wherever and
actually remove them as what they call
slag from the coin that was awarded so
what is sitting on the balance sheet of
that company
called bit zero it's their first
facility but they're contemplating ones
in upstate new york tennessee montana
and the amount of capital they're going
to burn up doing this is hundreds of
millions of dollars but it's there from
institutions that are taking their money
out of the public stocks that are going
to get audited so i'm arguing that
bitcoin mining is good for
sustainability it's good for longevity
it's good for productivity and it's
going to do something that's really
important for america it's going to put
those turbines back in those dams
because that's the number one use and
then they'll let the communities use
excess power where it's when it's needed
i think this is a good thing and this is
going to be one of the big topics that
you're going to hear about at bitcoin
2022 in fact there's multiple keynotes
around this whole issue because of the
squeeze happening right now on this esg
thing and esg has to be dealt with the
private sector the public sector the
president the loomis all of these bills
the sec they're coming down hard on
carbon and carbon audits and it's going
to affect this industry in a really i
argue
positive way
except if you're an existing bitcoin
miner that is using carbon credits then
you're screwed all right so kevin let me
understand this because um we know that
elon musk michael sailor they launched
the bitcoin mining council last year in
response to these esg concerns we've had
several guests on kitko saying what
you're saying that bitcoin mining is
actually facilitating the development of
green energy resources because it's
funding these projects so it's good for
decarbonization in the sense that as
you're saying that it's it's funding
alternative sources of energy
does it come a point though
that boards looking at esg then view
that as a positive and saying we'll
invest in bitcoin because it serves to
promote uh development and funding of
clean energy sources do you see that
flip happening
not yet the only the only funds that
have
done this
have been sovereign so far i think it
will happen i think after the norway
project is proven which would be in
about 12 to 14 months that will become
the model that same model will show up
in montana it'll show up in upstate new
york and tennessee everywhere where
there's excess power available that's
the model that they're going to use now
the fact that you've got institutions
funding it and the reason i know this is
i actually became an emirati citizen six
months ago just so i could vest
alongside them and i'm very proud of
that but i own a piece of that norway
facility and that is for me
solves my problem nobody can give me an
esg audit there's nothing to audit i
have no carbon there's zero zero zero
carbon there so all of this noise that's
coming at everybody
about this is i'm saying what carbon
we're just using hydroelectricity and
we're doing it on a sustainable model
and we're providing for the university
and up in norway
access to high-speed computers and on
top of this i mean this you couldn't
even dream of when they built it they
put beside it a hydroponic stack for
tomatoes and a tinning canning plant and
they take the heat off the stacks and
grow tomatoes talk about community i
mean they don't want to lose that
bitcoin mine now it's not one of these
miners that rips into town mines some
coin gets awards and blows out these
guys have long term power at under four
cents a kilowatt hour so the whole point
is that is the model and i think that's
what's going to solve this problem for
potus's executive order what larry fink
wants to do what the sec is doing but
right now
as you pointed out nobody very few
institutions are taking that they're
just staying away from you completely
because they're saying esg mandates too
scary carbon diode's too scary sec too
scary you know we don't want to lose
blackrock in terms of managing our funds
all of this stuff and we're going to
wait for the loomis bill to come out so
right we're in the transition period roy
pointed that out but i bet you when we
have this conversation the two of us
again in a year it's going to be
remarkably different all right
i completely agree with you kevin i i
actually think that there's even more
optimism here
because i i actually run an ethereum
mine in upstate new york and it's
getting so expensive right now that you
basically can't do it using hydrocarbons
and that's what's happening all around
the world the increase in the oil price
and the resulting increase in energy
costs has meant that unless your power
is essentially free you can't do it and
hydrocarbons will never be free because
there will always be a demand for
hydrocarbons right all right what does
this mean it means hydro and it means
potentially even gen 4 nuclear is going
to be the source but i also want to put
this in perspective here
i think most people have heard a lot
about bitcoin and all their all the
terrible energy use of bitcoin the total
energy use of bitcoin
just think for a moment what percentage
of global energy of global carbon
emissions come from bitcoin but what
would you say that number is
the answer is 1 500th
the gold mining industry is three times
the carbon emission of bitcoin
airplanes use 50 times the carbon
emission of bitcoin
and and so on you can i mean
so my point here is that
there's a flip side of this there's a
social good
billions of people having access to
stable right investments etc if you like
that video wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe